buongiorno allora avete vi ha spiegato
luigino quale era l'ambiente dove è
cominciato a nascere con la macchina lì
che vedete anche sullo schermo primo
personal computer programma 101
ecco era un ambiente io dico uno dei
motivi per cui ha potuto nascere questa
macchina già a quel tempo li e proprio
per il fatto che in quell'ambiente
c'erano tutte le conoscenze necessarie e
è già infatti era in produzione e quello
che era l'elea 9003 in questo ambiente e
qui si vede uno degli ambienti della
costruzione la produzione delle anno
2003 era avvenuta alla riorganizzazione
dovuta alla morte di ciò che è avvenuto
alla fine del 61 tra l'altro anch'io ho
avuto la fortuna di incontrarlo e di
conoscerlo e lui che mi ha assunto però
è morto purtroppo un mesetto dopo la mia
assunzione c'è stata la riorganizzazione
l'ingegner perotto aveva la mansione un
po distaccato da quelli che erano i
grossi calcolatori lele all'evoluzione
delle le ha sostanzialmente e il dottor
roberto olivetti gli ha detto ma perché
con la tecnologia che noi abbiamo perché
abbiamo già fatto le le ha e non
proviamo a fare in modo elettronico
quello che sono le macchine che invece a
ivrea facciamo meccaniche era sembrava
una bella sfida sembrava quasi che fosse
la richiesta di uno studio per fare
qualcosa di riempitivo far fare qualcosa
al gruppo dei jet per 8 ma perchè perchè
lady v summa e le tetraktis e guarda
caso fatte di ferro costavano 39.000
dire venivano vendute a 400mila lire
ecco un transistor costava più di mille
riera da solo quindi capite un messaggio
in questo genere cosa voleva dire
sicuramente voleva dire fare qualcosa
che rispetto alle macchine meccaniche
sarebbe stato fuori mercato però
l'ingegner perotto la presa con uno
spirito
c'è molto pratico cioè lui quale un
affido a lui ha detto vogliamo provare a
fare qualcosa allora invece di usare
tutta la tecnologia delle le 9300
partendo dalla memoria la memoria del re
a 9300 una una vera ram memoria a nuclei
in cui i moduli e avevano circa un mezzo
metro cubo di volume avevano un sacco di
circuiteria per l'indirizzamento dei
vari nuclei e guarda caso tra l'altro il
gruppetto di perotto stava già
utilizzando e cercando di fare delle
macchine partendo dalla memoria nuca ma
faro delle memorie nuclei più piccole i
moduli dell'area erano da 10k e allora
ha detto noi cominciamo a cercare una
memoria alternativa che ci consenta eg
garantisca di poter fare una macchina al
minimo di quello che sono i costi e ha
detto visto lui insegnava aveva fatto
dei libri di sauro meccanismi ha detto
da qualche parte so che usano hanno
usato delle memorie molto semplice che
sono le linee magneto street ive linea
magneto stretti va lì c'era laboratorio
di fisica ha chiesto laboratorio di
fisica di fare una linea magneto
ostruttiva e noi ci ha fatto vedete
quella che c'è sul tavolo quello un
tavolo di recupero di una porta
verniciata e un facendo di file di
nichel che ha due bombolette di
scrittura e un addirittura più semplice
di così sostanzialmente come schema che
me ne scappato 1
mi manca una slide scusate ma comunque
allora ve lo racconto a voce
sostanzialmente il filo che presenta il
fenomeno della magia costrizione ci
mette una bobina all'inizio si scrivono
in pool sino alla fine si mette un altro
bambinetta che legge l'impulso meccanico
perché la magnetizzazione dice che un
pezzo di metallo di che ha queste
caratteristiche sottoposto a un campo
magnetico guarda k una variazione di
campo magnetico cambia la sua dimensione
e quindi tutto sommato si genera un
impulso meccanico che poi viene
letto e se viene rigenerato si è il
concetto della memoria poi nello
scatolino vedete quello che
ingegnerizzata invece la linea memoria
che è andata in produzione
adesso andiamo a vedere ecco a un certo
punto noi con la linea ma niente
ostruttiva prototipare di questo genere
abbiamo preso dalla produzione delle
9300 un po di circuiteria e alla fine
del 62 abbiamo fatto vedere all'ingegner
perotto stampavamo dei risultati di
somme su una scrivente araba arabo
perché così stampa va automaticamente
dalla destra capito che con circa 150
gate di allora riuscivamo a fare le
operazioni abbiamo detto allora andiamo
avanti e abbiamo detto cosa facciamo
abbiamo deciso di fare una macchina
programmabile però programmabile vuol
dire subito un linguaggio di
programmazione linguaggio di
programmazione doveva essere
estremamente semplice abbiamo preso il
linguaggio di programmazione di quello
che erano le macchine da calcolo e
abbiamo cercato di allungo di estenderlo
linearmente abbiamo esteso infatti il
concetto è lo stesso c'è un tasto che ha
un singolo quello corrisponde a una
funzione
abbiamo fatto un linguaggio di 15
istruzioni in cui sono tutte intuitive
oltre alle operazioni ci sono movimenti
di dati
l'ingresso di dati in uscita di dati e
in più abbiamo introdotto 4 istruzioni
di salto che guarda caso essendo salto a
riferimento hanno una caratteristica che
non c'è nessun bisogno di fare calcoli
indirizzi eccetera e quindi abbiamo
creato un linguaggio che non ha bisogno
di nessuno strumento 1 a 1 fra il
simbolo che c'è in tastiera e quello che
c'è poi in memoria sotto forma di
programma è commettere facevamo questa
definizione di linguaggio già un lavoro
complesso ma che alla fine è arrivato a
una buona soluzione
dicevamo si ma non possiamo mica dare
una note le scriventi a ciascuno di chi
volesse avere questa macchina e quindi
dovevamo trovare qualcuno che ci facesse
un oggetto per stampare e
un oggetto stampare pilotato dal
qualcosa di elettronico allora non c'era
però qualcuno ci ha detto guardate che
c'è un gruppetto e in olivetti e questo
è stato il colpo di fortuna che ha fatto
qualcosa simile a quello che voi cercate
in effetti siamo andati a trovarli e
questi qui e era un gruppetto un po
emarginato abbia capito perché
emarginato aveva fatto qualcosa che era
proprio l'opposto di quello che era il
concerto della stampa la macchina
scrivere perché macchine da scrivere
cos'è un bastoncino che ha un simbolo in
rilievo batte su un nastro inchiostrato
che batte sulla carta e stampa
questi che aveva fatto proprio tutto
l'opposto ha messo i simboli sotto su un
rullo sopra si mette la carta sopra si
mette l'altro e c'è un martelletto
piatto che guarda caso va a bath però
guarda che questa stampa dina stampa 30
gradi e il secondo ed è il minimo di
dimensione però abbiamo adottato lottato
tutto il gruppo che tanto aveva poco da
fare perché era emarginato e e con loro
abbiamo costruito giusta parte meccanica
perché in questo oggetto ancora una
buona parte meccanica
abbiamo realizzato la macchina con quel
linguaggio pezze al tam pantina una
tastierina che ci hanno fatto questi e
su recco una cosa così e l'abbiamo
presentato ci siamo resi conto subito
che aveva un handicap l'abbiamo capito
noi non ha dovuto dice nessuno cioè
quando spegnere la macchina per devin
tutto quando dovevi cambiare programma
dovevi reintrodurre tutto il programma
può essere lungo 120 istruzioni abbia
capito che se tutte le volte mi metto
introdurre qualcosa di così lungo poi
alla fine non sono sicuro di averlo
introdotto bene quindi devo li debba
gare il programma non è una cosa banale
e era perdere il tempo il vantaggio
della macchina e allora abbiamo detto
definiamo un qualche cosa che ci
consenta di caricare i programmi
automaticamente sulla macchina abbiamo
la fine dopo varie soluzioni avevamo
fissato anche un dischetto scelto il più
semplice che è una striscia è una
cartolina magnetica e abbiamo realizzato
un secondo livello di macchina
reingegnerizzata tra tom che avesse
anche questo sistema se lo passi in
registrazione lui si carica il contenuto
della memoria e quindi il programma
sulla striscia magnetica se invece lo
passi in lettura
il programma viene caricato
automaticamente in questione di un
secondo e quindi la macchina è pronta
poi cambiare programma nel giro di un
secondo e quindi sono le application
sostanzialmente e quindi questa macchina
ingegnerizzata e cioè lin gerber 8 ha
detto qua tra l'altro era il momento in
cui lo diventi aver studiato e ha dovuto
vendere alla generale elettrica e quello
che era tutto la sua divisione
elettronica negli per otto ragazzi ha
detto fotografiamo sennò tra un po non
so come va a finire
nessuno crede che cosa quello che
abbiamo fatto e questo è guarda caso il
gruppettino c'è però tre sono io c'è
l'ingegner de sandre con la meccanica
che poi verrà messa e scatolato una
volta che abbiamo completato il
debugging di questa macchina in una
macchina vestita dal gruppo di meccanici
con la lamiera e vedo che sono andato
oltre comunque questo è quella che è
stata chiamata la per tina era in attesa
del vestito di mario bellini che l'ha
fatto diventare una cosa meravigliosa da
museo d'arte moderna e l'abbiamo
lanciata negli stati uniti purtroppo
come diceva luigino il tempo è poco
perché ci sarebbe tutto a raccontare la
storia del lancio e del gradimento della
macchina nel mercato americano
grazie
ecco